so the end result tom brady gets super
bowl ring
number seven here he is declining
to prioritize which ring means more than
the other and which one may mean the
most
every year is different you know this
year has been so it's been incredible
for me i
it's just been incredible so i
it's great that's that's where i rank it
it's great
you know brady used to say when asked
what's his favorite super bowl win he
would say the next one
and i guess he can't really say the next
one anymore because at 43 you can't
presume there's going to be a next one
but a lot of people do assume there's
going to be an external i think what
they did last night was the bookend
to
what they did with the patriots to the
rams 19 years ago when the rams were 14
point favorites
and the bucket and the patriots the
buccaneers i used to have a hard time
not calling the buccaneers the patriots
now i'm going to have a hard time not
calling the patriots the buccaneers but
the patriots
won that game and that was before
anybody really knew who brady was there
was a question early in the week as to
whether or not brady was even going to
play in that game he got injured in the
afc championship played seven days
before the super bowl drew bledsoe came
in and finished the job won the game and
then went back to the bench but uh that
to me was the most impressive because it
was the most unlikely i've i felt like
the patriots were going to win every
super bowl that they were in since then
and i ultimately felt like they were
going to win yesterday because of tom
brady's presence
yeah tom brady's not going to rank them
but we certainly can mike and you never
forget your first one like you said just
they were big underdogs in that game the
rams were supposed to come out and kill
them they didn't do it
the patriots won that game i think the
other one that was really special for
him was the seahawks victory in 2014
because of
the gap there because people forget he
wanted
2001 2003 2004 then there was that whole
gap when we wondered whether tom brady
would ever win another super bowl after
his third and he got back there in 14
and and won it in 14 and then obviously
16 and now we've come to expect brady to
win it but mike when you look at the
margins of victory for him in the super
bowl total margins of victory in his
first six super bowls was 19 points he
won this one by 22 points in my mind
this was brady's greatest victory ever
because of his age because of covid
because of no off season program coming
to a new team learning a new offense i
to me it's the greatest accomplishment
he's ever had uh and that's saying
something because he's had a lot of
these
i'm not ready to go quite that far
because coming back from 28 to 3 i think
was the moment he vaulted to the same
level as a michael jordan even though it
put him at five
super bowl wins and there was a sense
that maybe that was the perfect moment
for him to drop the mic and walk off
into the sunset he's won half of the
super bowls since that day in houston
four years ago but you mentioned the the
win over the seahawks that came 14 days
after
deflategate emerged
and the nfl eventually would come down
hard on him with the four game
suspension that was served to start the
2016 season to me that was
a meaningful victory because they had to
prove that they could win without
footballs that may or may not have had
the top taken off of them as people
around the league were saying at the
time so look they're all special they're
all significant and he now has seven of
them and it's that mentality they
brought to the buccaneers that the
buccaneers believe pushed them over the
top took them from seven and nine to 11
and five and super bowl champion here's
coach bruce erins and mike evans talking
about the mentality that tom brady
brings to a locker room
i think the leadership that tom brings
and his attitude that
hey let's go play
um
it's never over until it's over and
we're going to win this thing somehow
some way and uh
you know it permeated through our whole
locker room his belief
um that we're gonna do this
and knowing that he'd been there and
done it our guys
believed it and uh
it changed our entire football team it
was it was instant i mean
you if you had tom brady you know the
greatest quarterback all the time um
you know that
that's gonna do it itself you know um
and we had a lot of great players around
them and if you give you know the gold
all these players and um
you know it's going to work out and uh
it did
oh it definitely did and you know what
something that dawned on me earlier
today shireen
the torment that tom brady experienced
in losing three super bowls
that i think makes him even more
determined to not lose another one when
you think about how close the games were
that his teams won
the games he lost were just as close and
he was favored in each of those three
games if i recall correctly they were
18-0 when they lost to the giants they
faced the giants again four years later
and lost that one by narrow margin and
then
he had 500 passing yards in the super
bowl lost three years ago in minnesota
to the eagles he did everything in his
power to will the team to victory and
was unable to do it i think the losses
are so
painful
and so permanent
that the more he's lost the more
determined he becomes
never to lose again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports